god send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
no shock here kanye west isn't too happy
about pete davidson spending time with
his kids
i never want the person that i'm dating
to be like subjected to public scrutiny
just because we're dating he knows what
he's getting himself into obviously but
i'm trying to minimize any tabloid drama
seems like kanye's ex-wife kim
kardashian is over the drama surrounding
her relationship with pete davidson the
latest yay being territorial about their
six-year-old son according to an e.t
source quote kanye is very upset that
pete was out with saint he feels very
hurt and expressed his feelings to kim i
just want a drama-free
life and it's like there's always
headlines and this and this and this
even if there's things that are
inaccurate it's not like i could get out
there and be like hey this is wrong this
is wrong this is wrong meanwhile pete
seems open to extending an olive branch
to the rapper for kim's sake a source
else e.t pete is willing to meet up with
kanye and speak to him if it will help
pete just won't put up with any crap
from kanye and doesn't want kim to
either you just gotta roll with it from
what we've seen play out on the hulu
show it seems that kim's estranged
husband kanye dislikes pete and the fact
that she's moving on pete said i'm gonna
grow on you just just wait he's like
you're you're gonna
he knew he's like i give it four months
in and you're gonna be obsessed and i
was like oh
we'll see however the scams founder has
been dating the snl alum for six months
now so naturally it seems that kim would
introduce pete to her four kids north
saint chicago and psalm he's really
really thoughtful and humble and just so
genuine i would say the perfect word to
describe pete is genuine things may be
rocky with kanye and pete but he's
making a good impression with kim's
family we're told pete is great with the
kids our source added the kids love pete
too and have so much fun with him pete
is has got to be literally the best
human being i've ever met like the best
heart
lately we've seen kim totally smitten
with her beau on the hulu show which
echoes what she told et back in april
what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him he's just super
genuine yeah and it's just really fun to
just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing and it's
that same joyful energy her family
notices in the 41 year old star our
source says kim has laughed more with
pete than she has in years
i definitely noticed that kim is happier
i think that she's so much nicer now
thank you pete i'm so into this new kim
we have a feeling we know why pete is
keeping a smile on kim's face pete was
like babe let's go get some ice cream at
thrifty and i was like
oh my god
you are making me so
corny right aid thrifty it was literally
like one of the best nights of my life
[Music]
you